scarlet I took this personally you were
a redhead and then you transition to
block this role and I was crushed
because there's like four of us left
left in the universe we are a dying
breed and then you decided to give up
team red head and go blonde didn't you
feel this sudden loss of like sexual
power yes I did I was willing to give it
up though yeah yeah to fight the good
fight because you know I my roots and I
still have red roots I just have to
bleach them every two and a half weeks
right Yeah right
I'm just was I was shocked I was it I
was so happy that there was that was the
most shocking thing about this phone was
the fact that I had blonde hair yeah
that was the part that I went right to
immediately I was very unhappy about it
I'm sorry I took it personally what you
know I'm sorry honestly I you know I
thought that my character was you know
making sort of a creative choice and I
didn't realize I would be so offensive
to well all four of you but
actually there's three of us now one of
them just died and the other is in a cop
you